we're often told to follow our passion
if we want to be happy in life but
here's why multi-millionaire
entrepreneur Grace Beverly thinks this
advice can be dangerous one of the
downfalls of passions is that you're
probably not going to realize when
you're burnt out because there's this
like necessity whether internal or
external because it's a business that
you put into a lot of money into or
internal because you believe in it so
much and you love it and you really want
it to succeed it's like when you're
working for ages and you don't realize
until you look up how long you've been
working for and you're really like your
whole brain's just Zapped and I think
that we don't talk about how exhausting
working on something you're passionate
about can be because you exert yourself
that much more now that's not to say
that it's as like I've mentioned it's
not to say that it's not a hugely
privileged position because it is but I
also think that when we're encouraging
like work on your passion like all of
this also remembering the fact that if
you're there every day so trying to make
this idea into a business and so trying
to make this work and so trying to get
your side hustle off the ground and all
of these things you're also allowed to
feel burnt out